Everyone knows who won.
But not everyone knows how.
We are about to ask the biggest
question in a generation.
In or out? And we need a leader.
(EXHALES)
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC) ♪
DOMINIC CUMMINGS: We need to
understand who our voters are.
Appeal to their hearts.
People are feeling angrier,
ignored. Is it immigration?
You can be honest.
Is it race?
Which countries don't you like?
-New people come in--
-We get squeezed out.
CUMMINGS: We want to return to
a time when we knew our place,
and when things made sense.
Fictional or not.
How to change
the course of history:
-We have to hack
the political system.
-Hack it?
I'm talking about altering
the matrix of politics.
ZACK MASSINGHAM:
Social media platforms
are designed
to find like-minded people.
Our software will locate
and target
people that no campaign
has ever targeted before.
People who don't,
and have never voted.
Three million extra votes
that the other side
have no idea exist.
CUMMINGS: This is an insurgence
against the establishment.
We're going to build something
that will restack the odds
in our favor.
WOMAN: What are your
expectations, realistically?
To create the biggest
political upset
since the fall
of the Berlin Wall.
-Ready to launch?
-Yeah.
Let's take back control!
Now, the fight
for Britain begins!
You are feeding a toxic culture
of fear and hate.
You can't close the box
once it's been opened.
It's your edge, newly found.
CUMMINGS:
There is a new politics in town.
One that you cannot control.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪